so you want to make a lot of money fast
but going to college working your way up
the corporate ladder or even doing
illegal stuff just isn't your thing you
need something that is a little morally
gray but still perfectly legal you need
something that doesn't require a lot of
licenses or money to start where you can
immediately start making a ton of cash
and that's when you stumble across the
opportunity of a lifetime becoming a
body broker you know what the following
video may contain upsetting and graphic
content viewer discretion is advised
see when someone does and chooses to
donate their body to science a body
broker is the person that takes their
body processes it and sends that body
where it needs to go and before you say
gross there is no way I'm doing this
know that for every body you collect you
can sell it for at least five thousand
dollars now do I have your attention and
you don't even need any special licenses
or equipment to do it all you need is a
strong stomach and the right connections
how easy is it for someone to enter
do you have a Sawzall
you have a garage a person with no
medical experience no funeral director's
license was able to open up a whole body
donation program take possession of a
human body dismember it send it
throughout the nation without any type
of Licensing oversight it's harder to
sell hot dogs on a cart than it is to
get into this business this is the
gruesome yet profitable business of body
brokers
[Music]
foreign
part of the reason why this industry is
so sketchy is because of just how much
demand there is for bodies doctors need
something to study right and one company
that's helping solve this problem in a
much more ethical way is called
shapeways if you haven't heard of
shapeways they are revolutionizing
manufacturing by making 3D printing
faster cheaper and more accessible than
ever before and one of their clients is
armor bionics armor bionics makes
medical models that are so accurate they
have been described as a GPS for
surgeons and the only way they're able
to do this is because they use shapeways
to 3D print their models with pinpoint
accuracy without costing an arm and a
leg and in the future all manufacturing
is going to be like this instead of
buying expensive equipment creating
expensive molds you can just send your
design to a company like shapeways and
they will print it for you on demand and
shapeways is already in the perfect
position to dominate this revolution
shapeways is a public company backed by
Blue Chip investors like a16z and
they've got clients like Microsoft NASA
and Whirlpool we'll go over more about
shapeways later but if you want to learn
more pause the video and go to jake.yt
shapeways with the link below that's
jake.yt shapeways with the link below
shapeways is the paid sponsor of this
video now back to the video
donating your body versus donating your
organs are two very different things
organ donors donate things like their
organs eyes Skin and Bones to help cure
people's diseases and to assist in
Medical Treatments and to work in the
organ donation field you will need a
long list of licenses and certifications
but the most important downside is that
you can't sell organs in the US it's
very illegal however these rules don't
apply to body Brokers
non-transplant anatomical donation or
donating your body to science is very
different not only do you not need any
licenses to work with body donations
you're also completely free to sell
those donated bodies and body parts for
as much money as you want in a perfect
world body donations will go to medical
schools universities and medical
researchers to help them create new
medications to help them create new test
tools and for them to practice
complicated surgeries on each donated
body would be carefully and respectfully
processed and once they had served their
purpose they would be collected cremated
and the ashes returned to their families
but this isn't a perfect world and these
dead bodies are as good as cold Hard
Cash
foreign
[Music]
setting up your company you want to call
it something low-key like Science Care
or biological Resource Center these are
real body broker companies by the way
you want to make it sound vague and as
general as possible so you don't sound
like you're making money selling body
parts you wanted to make a sound like a
highly specialized medical company that
will be carefully overseeing the
donation of human bodies instead of a
corpse profiteer oh and don't worry
about any fancy licenses or regulations
there are almost no restrictions on who
can buy and sell human remains
we process around a thousand deer a year
for the Hunting Community we process uh
bears and anything you can imagine we
process okay any uh any humans in here
we we do we have a few human here that
are waiting to be finished oh wow
and this is a donor human here this
comes from the human body donor programs
once people are dead they are no better
than animals ready to be dissected and
experimented on but obviously you don't
want your customer base to know that
then they might rethink their choice
which brings us to The Next Step
foreign
[Music]
desperation they don't pursue their
dreams so they're just yearning for a
chance to feel importance especially
when they're on their deathbed and what
better way to feel important than to
donate your body to Advanced Medical
studies you have the chance to give an
anatomical gifts and I'm just here to
provide you with options in your time of
need these are the heartstrings that you
want to be pulling on this is the last
great thing you can do with your lives
after all by donating your body to
science you could be helping a doctor
discover the cure for cancer wouldn't
you want to contribute to curing cancer
your small Sacrifice by signing on this
dotted line can change the world forever
there that will make them feel important
because remember each body I mean
customer will give you a nice five
thousand dollars or more so you want to
put a lot of thought into the marketing
here and whatever you do you don't want
to bore people with a gruesome harsh
reality of what will happen to their
bodies after they die and your ideal
customer for this marketing scheme why
the old and the poor
foreign
[Music]
so you've got your company ready and
you've got your messaging on points now
all you need is for people to sign up
but here's the thing No One's Gonna sign
up for someone to cut their body into
pieces if they don't have a guarantee
that their ashes will be returned to
their families one day so to get around
this you have to get creative first you
want to set up the donation paperwork to
be so long and complicated so that no
one ever reads the fine print about what
you'll be really doing with their bodies
once they're dead then to make extra
sure that no one asked too many
questions you want to Target sick old
people in hospices and other end of Life
Care Centers people on the verge of
death don't have time to read paperwork
they don't care about the terms and
conditions they just want to know that
their life meant something that they're
still going to do something great after
death so they sign on the dotted line
just like that but that's not enough if
you want to make real money you're gonna
need more than just one sick old person
dying every now and then you need a
steady flow of product I mean patience
so next up you want to Target the poor
here's the thing the average funeral
costs seven thousand dollars even a
simple cremation can cost a thousand
dollars when I'm dead just throw me in
the trash people in poverty can't afford
that so why not offer them a cheaper
more dignified alternative donate your
loved one's body to science and we'll
even pay for the cremation for you that
way instead of having to pay a few racks
it won't cost you a sense and you'll be
sleeping easy knowing that your family
member's body is being used for
something great and guess what nine
times out of ten they always say yes
after all you are getting these poor
families at their worst at their most
vulnerable what kind of a son or
daughter isn't gonna give their parent a
proper goodbye every year more than 20
000 people donate their bodies to
science either because they think it
will make a difference or because they
can't afford the alternatives
[Music]
thank you
okay so you know how the business works
you know your pitch now it's time to
guarantee that you have a steady supply
of dead bodies and nowhere where you
find a more readily available supply of
dead bodies than funeral homes so here's
what you gotta do approach funeral homes
and offer Funeral Home directors
Kickbacks for referring families that
donate bodies to you an affiliate
program funeral homes already have to
constantly reject people who can't
afford their services so instead of
sending them home why not send them to
you and get a commission maybe you even
go a step further and convince Theodore
home workers to send you bodies without
the consent of their families and her
mother Shirley Coke are now under arrest
for a legally selling body parts or
entire bodies without consent from
family members attorneys for the victims
called Hess and Koch Body Snatchers the
company was a recognized non-profit
Corporation but earned hundreds of
thousands of dollars charging
approximately 560 grieving families for
cremations that never occurred instead
of their loved ones remains families
were given Burns filled with sand
concrete and cat litter think about it
none of the family members are ever
going to figure out that that's not
their dead grandma or Grandpa's ashes
and if that's not enough why not just
vertically integrate and open up a
funeral home yourself that way you cut
out the middleman and do all the body
brokering in-house and with all the
supply that you could possibly need it's
time to head on to the easiest stuff
processing
[Music]
thank you if you were unethical body
donation company you would probably
invest in specialized equipment
industrial freezers and experience
employees but you don't have time for
that so you switch out the medical tools
for chainsaws you buy a few cheap
restaurant freezers and you employ
anyone with a stomach to cut up human
bodies the bodies coming into your
literal Chop Shop are nothing more than
Commodities with set prices for each
parts a brain goes for 750 a foot for
200 a hand for 250 a head for 500 but
late for 1300 a torso for 2100 and a
whole body for around five thousand
dollars all you gotta do is embalm the
body cut it up into usable pieces label
and freeze those pieces and send them
out to the universities and hospitals
that ordered them and if you're thinking
that this sounds too simple to be true
it really is that simple with a chainsaw
a freezer and a couple of cheap
chemicals you can start making money
from body donations in just a few weeks
one body donation center literally had a
guy defrosting a body with a hose pipe
outside that is just how little
regulation there is in this industry and
it's not as if he only sell to
universities or Med schools yet the
military needs a body to test a bomb on
you're their guy his mom's body
according to Reuters was sold to the U.S
military she was then supposedly
strapped in a chair on some sort of an
apparatus and a a detonation took place
underneath her if some scientists wanted
to dissect the body in front of a paying
audience they come to you and if some
internet creep wants to buy a body or a
head for some unknown reason who are you
to judge maybe he's going to cure cancer
one day the minute your donor or their
family sign the contract they handed you
total control of how the body is used
whether it's blown up chopped into a
hundred pieces or is never properly
cremated and returned no one can hold
you accountable because technically they
sign ownership of that body over to you
and with both the law and the money on
your side it doesn't take long but for
the big bucks they're rolling in
foreign
this is Jim Rogers between 2012 and 2014
him and his wife Josie made more than
12.5 million dollars as body Brokers
through their company's Science Care Jim
said he wanted to turn Science Care into
the McDonald's of the body brokering
world where every franchise offered the
same quality and prices for parts in
2016 Jim and Josie sold Science Care to
a billion dollar company the sale
included quote written pledges for more
than a hundred thousand people to donate
their bodies to Science Care when they
die End quotes Jim was so good at his
job that he worked out exactly what it
would cost to process a body down to the
very last sense according to him Science
Care was making
677.55 or around a thousand dollars
today in profits for everybody it
processed and sold by 2011 Science Care
was taking in and selling
3886 bodies a year so use Jim and
Josie's example as a blueprints they
made Millions selling body parts in an
industry where no one can get arrested
and the best parts nothing has changed
since Jim and Josie made their Millions
no new laws have been introduced no
International outrage no new licenses
you need to apply for even after all the
gruesome stories that have surfaced it's
still easier than ever to become a body
broker but there is hope in the future
we may be able to just 3D print organs
and body parts in the lab and when it
comes to printing human body parts the
future is already here just in the last
few months we have seen some pretty
incredible results one woman received a
3D printed ear implant made from her own
cells as part of a clinical trial
doctors in France were able to grow a
new nose for a cancer patient using 3D
printed cartilage and get this
researchers at MIT can now print 3D
replicas of the human heart and if 3D
printing organs becomes the norm this
whole body trait industry will
completely collapse or at least not be
as bad as it is right now earlier in the
video you already learned about how the
company shapeways is already printing
ultra realistic medical models that
surgeons can use to study and plant
surgeries on but in the future it won't
just be organs and medical models that
are 3D printed but only everything
around you see traditionally to
manufacture something you have to Mill
expensive injection modes by super
expensive equipment which meant that
manufacturing physical products was only
reserved from the biggest corporations
but now all of that is changing now if
you want to build and sell something all
you have to do is design it on your
computer upload it to shapeway's website
press order and shapewist will print it
using plastic or metals and then it will
be shipped right to your door so as you
can imagine this is going to change
manufacturing forever the manufacturing
industry is worth over two trillion
dollars or bigger than the country of
Canada as shape waste is in the perfect
position to completely disrupt it
they've manufactured over 24 million
Parts their clients range from Microsoft
to NASA to Whirlpool their printing
quality is good enough for Aerospace and
the medical field and they're a public
company backed by Blue Chip investors
like a16z and if any of this sounds
interesting to you and you want to learn
more about shapeways pause the video and
go to jake.yt shapeways with the link
below that's jake.yt Safeways with the
link below thanks to shapeways for being
the paid sponsor of this video
[Music]
thank you
foreign